there's miles teller that's cool yeah
software what up guys
hope you guys are surviving quarantine
alright grateful for the podcast while
I'm at home doing nothing uh I got a
candor sting it re dosing Burt I don't
know if I heard you guys talk about it I
know it's been a while but uh what do we
say King at her sing it Gang Gang
buzz-buzz shutout dick boy bike club
shout-out Dicky
damn it's a movement shut up Vicky those
drops Friday to do does it yeah it's a
gift it's a shitty gift I have but it's
a gift is that that guy a miles teller
yep
it's a real [ __ ] gift I have that's a
good one I'm like Rain Man mm-hmm I
can't count that picture yeah shitty
gift that um already dosing Burt you
want to dive into this first I think
that Burt likes any height that he can
get I think he's ok with it in the end I
think it was a little risque in the
beginning my problem is doing it around
his family if it was like on the road or
something that's whatever cuz they're so
close he did it that's whatever the
problem is there's no consequence like
if I already did that to me a huge as
well just around my kids there's gonna
be repercussions that's the problem
he knows Burt's not can do anything yeah
you do have to Rogen there's gonna be
repercussions yeah you have to Tom it's
probably be repercussions
but Burt's so fun and playful that Burt
you know and Burt does they're close
though so it's like they're bought like
you would never do that to me right and
every crazy you would never do that to
me but again I I don't know the
relationship well enough but I you and
me are close you're my best friends if
you Brian or Rogen death to me dude I'd
I've put my hands on you yeah switch in
front of my kids I would get lucky
I'd do it just to get beat probably oh
there's your razor you about that bro
just to feel something you know people
aren't feeling it huh
sting it but again but if I you know re
demo you can play around we play around
like that right like I don't know the
relationship so if that's how they play
around who am I to say they should have
done it
he's like the Santa Claus kind of drugs
he like kind of shows up people don't
know if he's real and then he [ __ ]
drugs you you know hmm I know Bert was I
heard Bert was upset but then he seems
alright what then he seems alright with
it yeah so he said he said he had some
medical problems but he's always had
those I think since up no god that's his
weight right yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
what they said they were gonna replace
his heart at one point
oh sure with like a calf's heart or
something and then he's uh there but he
was going he's got a plane to it to go
and play nothing yeah he's not dude it
sounds like these guys a couple of [ __ ]
boys that's what it sounds like doing it
time for this [ __ ] also Birds too old to
be doing my [ __ ] bro that's the other
thing well what was it it also depends
on what type of drug it was it was Molly
it was a shitload of Molly or II I don't
know drugs is that this actually gets
fine dude it's just gonna end up in a
big-ass family hug and as long as they
get you out of the house after an hour I
think you're good you know it seems like
no no harm no foul I've been pissed I
don't play like that dude I've grown
with kids I can't but I can't play like
that
did it happen though do you guys think
out part of me wonders if it was
strategic to help you get hype for a
special though and to help get a re past
the COBE thing no this was before the
cousin thought it was oh never mind me
this is before all that I think that's
the relationship yeah that's what they
do
mask off yeah they've got a podcast
recorded that they never released
Burt thinks it'd be like irresponsible
or something but man that would crush
everybody knows about this it's like
legend now they need to release that
herb says he doesn't want to release it
right cuz ya say some he was really
upset at him right yeah he was worried
that like it would be bad influence on
children about drug like he's taking it
lightly he doesn't know if there's legal
repercussions he said which i think is
not really an issue cool children
yeah local children international
children at once it's insane and you're
gonna be too upset if they're still boys
yeah that's this thing you didn't put
any hand bro if you're upsetting them
[ __ ] shoot him
nothing's an you right shoot him cut him
kind of shank him yeah yeah what are you
gonna do oh you did nothing bro you did
nothing you ain't upset cuz i'm higher
you probably look like banana bread to
me i'm like the [ __ ] oh yeah at least
bite into your buddy's neck bro yeah
dawg teach him a lesson
yeah bite into your [ __ ] friend
nothing Burt yeah you did nothing Burt
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]